[موسيقى]
عندما كانوا كينيين ، لم
أطلب طلبًا تركيًا وكان فريق SWAT
موجودًا هناك لأنها قالت إن
أمريكا لا تعتقل في الأفق ، أوه ، لا توجد
قناة جديدة سهلة الاستخدام أخيرًا لا توجد أضرار وظيفية
إجمالاً أعرف  الكثير من الاتصالات يفعلها ما
لم يكن واجبًا في ذلك
، أعتقد أن لوسيان لرجل ثلج خارق ،
شخص جيد
[موسيقى]
نعم ، أعتقد أن أحدًا لي ،
ماذا أفعل ما أخبرك به ما زلت
رجلًا ، أعتقد أن مهنة يمكنني إضافتها
فندق  تصفح جوقة سارة ماكانودو
غدًا وإنهاء número الخاص بنا إذا
ألغيت صناعة التكنولوجيا
، قمت بإطلاق عملية مطاردة للكناري - أخذنا وأوريليا نيجاندا التي في وسائل الإعلام في هذا التناوب ثيتا ، قمنا بتهيئة
رسالة رادار بحرية إن شاء الله
[موسيقى]
تغيير أسلوب النقل بواسطة  اختيار
طفل الحمم الناس كتاب جديد ماوكلي
يسلح البنية التحتية لتكنولوجيا المعلومات في مدينة
أبالاتشيان
ناماستي الشيعة سخيفة جدًا نعم حول
ليليان
وغولدبرغ  دخل تشيني
سوف يقسم لسانه الشرير.
أنت تعرف عن
كوزكو العاجي الخوخي ، الفتنة
كابوت العاطفي الذي تم إطلاقه للطفل ، صحيح
الآن حتى الآن نظرًا لأن CUDA لا يوجد فيديو يغني
إلى جافا ، متفق عليه سيدي الثاني ،
ربما يكون مشكلة جيبوتي ، نبدأ
يومنا بتناول كوب من الشاي الذي
تضعه للطفل  على الموقد الخاص بك ، أول
شيء يستيقظ المنزل كله في الصباح
و تحصل على الرائحة في جميع
أنحاء المنزل ،
اسمي Sunita Banerjee أنا أعيش في
مومباي الهند ، والتوابل التي تطحنونها
معًا هي الزنجبيل والهيل والقرفة
، وإذا كنت تحب القليل منها
لإضافة القليل من الفلفل إلى خاص
، اجعلها أكثر توابلًا ، فقط قم بطحنها
معًا وإضافتها إلى
الماء المغلي وأوراق الشاي الخاصة بك أكوردي  نانوغرام حسب
ذوقك إذا كنت تحب قوتها
أكثر من ذلك بقليل ، وإلا فقط ملعقة صغيرة واحدة
لكل كوب تقريبًا ، دع
الخليط بالكامل يبدأ في الغليان أضف الحليب وشايك جاهزًا ،
سيقول والدي
أن كوب الشاي المثالي عندما
يكون لديك رشفة منه  يجب أن يمنحك
طعم بسكويت أعتقد أنه
يلعب دورًا مهمًا جدًا في
كل حياة الهنود